barack obama a eu cette phrase il y a
quelques semaines il n'y a pas de défi
qui présentent une plus grande menace
pour nous ou pour les générations
futures que le changement climatique
et cette phrase il l'a dit à un moment
clé au moment où cette année l'humanité
a éclusé toutes ses ressources pour
l'année aujourd'hui on vit avec les
ressources d'une seconde planète
totalement imaginaire qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que cette année
le 13 août
l'humanité a éclusé toutes les
ressources et l'énergie que la planète
est capable de lui produire pour l'année
comment on en est arrivé là on en est
arrivé là par une gestion un petit peu
catastrophique des ressources
je vais prendre un exemple tout simple
un exemple du quotidien on rentre de nos
courses qu'on a fait pour la semaine ou
pour le mois on ne sort tous nos sachets
ont des fêtes où on retire les
emballages des yaourts pour les ranger
au frigo on sort les gâteaux pour les
mettre dans notre boîte on n'a pas
encore commencé à consommer quoi que ce
soit qu'on va déjà m je ne sais pas
combien de déchets à la poubelle et ça
sera pareil quand on aura consommé nos
coton tige notre sopalin etc
à chaque fois qu'on va utiliser quelque
chose à chaque geste qu'on va faire dans
notre quotidien
on va mettre quelque chose à la poubelle
alors comment on fait nous pour arrêter
un de produire autant de déchets et 2
d'avoir recours systématiquement à les
produits jetables qu'on va devoir
racheter très prochainement
la réponse moi je les trouvais dans un
mode de vie qui s'appelle le zéro déchet
ça peut paraître impressionnant au
premier abord
j'ai souvent des réactions un peu genre
oulala ça va être ça doit être très
difficile à mettre en place mais je vous
réponds ce que je réponds à chaque fois
c'est pas une vie ou une autre qui est
plus difficile
c'est le changement entre les deux skis
à des fumeurs dans la salle est ce que
dans les fumeurs y en a qui ont déjà
essayé d'arrêter de fumer
demandez-leur au moment où ils sont en
train d'essayer d'arrêter de fumer si
c'est dur il dira oui demander un non
fumeur si c'est dur de ne pas fumer
il va vous dire non c'est pas une
situation où une autre qui est compliqué
c'est passé d'une situation à l'autre
parce que on va faire des erreurs
on va tester des choses et ça va être d
échec total mais on va trouver des
solutions
et petit à petit notre vie elle va
changer et elle va changer en mieux
alors comment on fait concrètement le
premier geste auquel on pense
quand on pense quel geste je peux faire
moi au quotidien en tant que citoyen
pour préserver l'environnement
on pense au tri ça c'est un geste qui
est assez facile à faire
et encore on se pose quand même pas mal
de questions souvent sur le podium ou
retour des choses comme ça et moi c'est
quelque chose qui me tenait à coeur de
bien faire le tri parce que j'étais
persuadé que c'était la seule chose que
je pouvais faire vraiment donc je
pouvais passer un quart d'heure à me
dire or tant veloppe je la mets au tri
ou pas alors c'est du papier donc oui
mais il ya une fenêtre en plastique
alors est-ce que ça va ou non donc
j'avais cherché sur internet juste pour
mettre un truc à la poubelle mais je le
mettais dans la bonne poubelle donc
j'étais fier de moi
et un jour je me suis rendu compte que
ça c'était bien c'était hyper important
de faire le tri mais en fait c'était le
dernier maillon de la chaîne
il y avait beaucoup plus à faire en
amont on a beaucoup plus de pouvoir que
ce qu'on croit on peut simplement éviter
de créer des déchets et c'est le
principe de base pour moi la ligne du
zéro déchet c'est vivre avec l'essentiel
consommer seulement l'essentiel pour
vivre toujours aussi bien selon nos
contraintes et nos besoins concrètement
comment on fait il va falloir faire
attention à trois choses va falloir
faire attention à ce qu'on fait rentrer
chez nous à ce qui est chez nous est-ce
qu'on sort de chez nous pour ce qui est
entre la toute première chose ça va être
deux
refusez vous commencez à refuser ce dont
on n'a pas besoin parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a un petit peu une maladie que
j'appelle la maladie du gratuit on a un
petit peu tendance à prendre les choses
qu'on nous propose sans spécialement se
demander si c'est utile ou pas soyons
honnêtes combien de stylos
promotionnelles ou de porte clés nous
avons chez nous à mon avis beaucoup trop
et simplement ce geste en fait de
refuser ce dont on n'a pas besoin
ça va pas changer concrètement notre
quotidien vous trouverez toujours un
stylo pour écrire il n'y a pas de
problème mais ça va simplement changer
le nombre de déchets avec vous produisez
en prolongeant cette réflexion je me
suis aussi rendu compte que on
consommait énormément à l'âge or quand
on achète un produit on achète le
produit
c'est ce dont on a besoin à l'intérieur
en fait on n'a pas besoin de l'emballage
en soit à part pour le transporter et
encore et donc j'ai commencé à refuser
les emballages comment en achetant en
vrac en faisant des sacs en faisant ma
mère ma cousine des sacs pour que je
transporte tout ce qui était proposé en
vrac
après il ya d'autres solutions on n'a
pas tous un magasin de vrac à côté de
chez nous mais en fait on s'en rend pas
compte mais au quotidien il ya beaucoup
de produits qui nous on prend qui nous
sont proposés à la vente sans aucun
emballage tous les fruits et légumes de
vos rayons de supermarchés traditionnels
le pain les croissante tout chez le
boulanger touché le fromager touché le
boucher et bien toutes ces choses là on
peut déjà les acheter sans emballage il
suffit de nous d'amener le nôtre qui va
être réutilisable à l'infini
plutôt que de prendre le sachet de la
baguette de pain qui va faire entre 30
secondes et 10 minutes suivant à quelle
distance on habite de la blanche ça
c'est la première chose
ensuite quand on fait des achats on peut
tout simplement faire des achats
d'occasion qui de base ne seront pas
emballé qui vont donner une seconde vie
à un objet et qui en plus auront
l'avantagé d'être moins cher en général
à nouveau quand on fait déjà on peut
penser durable plutôt que jetables
aujourd'hui quand on fait les courses on
a toute la partie alimentaire et on a
tout le reste
tout le reste il ya bien 90 % qui est
jetable les cotons pour se démaquiller
le sopalin à nouveau jeter un coup
d'oeil dans la cuisine ou la salle de
bain ça en regorge et bien tout ça pour
tous ses produits on peut trouver une
alternative réutilisables on a
l'habitude d'utiliser des lingettes pour
essuyer les meubles on peut prendre une
microfibre à la place on a l'habitude
d'utiliser des cotons démaquillants on
peut en prendre des qui cela va la
machine tout ça chaque produit chez nous
à une alternative réutilisables et après
dernière option on peut simplement ne
pas acheter ses pensées utilisation
plutôt que possession moi par exemple il
ya quelques années encore j'étais une
fan à de livres mais j'avais besoin de
les avoir à tel point que j'étais
capable de lire un ebook sur internet et
quitter le livre après en magasin pour
avoir la version physique à mettre dans
ma bibliothèque
c'était un petit peu fou aujourd'hui
j'ai une carte de bibliothèque
j'achète plus de livres j'en lis
toujours autant et me vis passe très
bien
donc ça c'est pour ce qui rentre chez
nous deuxième étape ce qui est chez nous
aujourd'hui un foyer possède environ
sept mille objets c'est énorme c'est
autant de personnes qui lie à l'île
saint denis
c'est énorme donc l'étape la première
étape pour vivre avec l'essentiel ça va
être de faire du tri dans tous ces
objets on a tendance à penser que du
coup si on fait du tri on va se
débarrasser de certaines choses et que
du coup on va produire plus de déchet
mais le produit ou l'objet qui est chez
vous au fond d'un placard ou plein de
poussière inutilisés il est pas mis en
valeur et c'est comme si c'était un
déchet sans compter le fait qu'un jour
vous en aurez marre et que de toute
façon vous jetterez du coup faut faire
le tri tout simplement il faut pas
simplement s'appuyer sur son jugement
parce que ça marche pas vraiment il ya
toujours une valeur sentimentale à tous
les objets qu'on a
moi personnellement je m'en suis très
bien
rendu compte avec ma garde-robe j'avais
un million de robes 40 paires
d'escarpins alors que j'en mets jamais
et du coup comment j'ai fait parce que
j'ai essayé de faire le tri plusieurs
fois il y avait beaucoup de choses qui
restaient dans mon armoire alors que je
les mettais pas j'ai adopté la technique
de la boîte des cimes comment ça marche
vous faites le tri vous vous dites ok
donc ça c'est super mais bon
concrètement je le met pas souvent tout
ça vous le mettez dans une boîte vous
fermer la boîte vous l'a scotché
vous écrivez la date dessus et vous
stockez la boîte au fond de votre
armoire
si dans les six mois vous n'avez pas eu
spontanément besoin d'aller chercher
quelque chose dans cette boîte
donnez là mais ne l'ouvré pas avant de
la donner
parce que vos escarpins vous retournez
direct dans l'armoire c'est sûr donc ça
pour faire le tri vous allez voir ça va
alléger votre quotidien
ça va être fantastique ensuite va le
reste il suffit de réparer entretenir ce
qu'on a
ça va leur donner une seconde vie vous
en pouvait plus de ce vieux meubles que
votre grand mère vous a légué vous
pouvez lui met un super coup de peinture
il n'y a pas de souci avec ça donc ça
c'est pour ce qu'on a chez nous il ya le
dernier petit point pour ce qu'on a chez
nous dans les objets qu'on n'utilise pas
souvent mais parce que ils sont pas
destinés à être utilisé très souvent on
pense à une perceuse ou un appareil à
raclette l'idée ça va être de les prêter
parce que concrètement votre appareil à
raclette
soit vous le sortez toutes les semaines
et auquel cas votre votre alimentation
risque de pu être tout à fait vrai
soit vous le prêter et ça va permettre
en fait aux gens à qui vous le prêter 2
2e pas avoir cet appareil à raclette et
ben c'est pareil le jour vous avez
besoin d'une perceuse
au lieu d'investir dans la perceuse
aller toquer chez votre voisin pour
savoir s'il en a une
parce que concrètement des rideaux vous
n'allez pas en poser tous les donc voilà
ça c'est quand on fait attention à ce
qu'ils achètent
dernière étape quand on a besoin de
faire sortir des choses de chez nous les
au quotidien quand on a besoin d'eux
t'épouse où justement après ces grandes
périodes de prix bas tout ce qui peut
être encore réutiliser il va falloir
leur donner une seconde vie simplement
les données les revendre et c'est le
reste qui doit vraiment aller à la
poubelle il va juste falloir faire
attention de le mettre dans la bonne
poubelle alors chez nous on a deux
poubelles en général on à la poubelle de
tri la poubelle d'ordures ménagères
parfois on à la poubelle de verre il n'y
a pas que ça il ya aussi les tissus par
exemple qui sont encore énormément jeter
dans la poubelle d'ordures ménagères
alors qu'il ya des bornes en fait pour
les amener voilà il faut juste trouver
le bon endroit où je t'ai l'objet et le
dernier petit point qui reste qui est
quand même un point assez important
c'est qu'il ya un tiers de notre
poubelle qui est constitué de biodéchets
les biodéchets c'est ce qui a été vive
en un jour donc généralement les
épluchures quand nous préparer à manger
où les restes de repas
donc pour ça il ya un outil fantastique
ça s'appelle le compost concrètement
quand on vit en ville
le compost un peu compliqué et du coup
il ya une solution qui s'appelle le
lombricompost moi la première fois qu'on
m'en a parlé
on m'a dit mais tu vas voir c'est
fantastique c'est une boîte tu peux
mettre des biodéchets dedans il ya des
verts qui vont manger tout ça est
transformé en terro il dit non non
attends moi j'habite dans un studio
c'est à dire que si je mets une boîte
avec des verts dans ma cuisine
il est aussi dans mon salon et dans ma
chambre
donc c'est pas possible évidemment pas
d'accord en fait je vais investir dedans
et je vais le mettre dans ma cave et en
fait ça fait six mois que c'est dans ma
cuisine et je vis très bien avec mes
verres il n'y a aucun souci
donc moi j'ai envie de dire investissez
dans un lombricompost ça va réduire d'un
tiers votre poubelle du jour au
lendemain
et si vous avez un immeuble et vous
pouvez vous pouvez mettre un vrai
compost masse est aussi l'occasion de
monter un projet avec vos voisins pour
avoir un contre pied d'immeuble donc
voilà ça c'est pour comment concrètement
faire les choses vous allez me dire
c'est super mais qu'est ce que ça
apporte
ça apporte plein de choses déjà vous
allez économiser énormément d'argent
il n'y a plus d'achats non alimentaire
moi à titre d'exemple je fais 10
rod achats non alimentaires par mois à
peu près quand pu besoin de racheter les
lingettes les coton etc
mais sur le budget ça allège énormément
vous allez gagner du temps on n'est plus
obligé de s'occuper de sept mille objets
mais de beaucoup moins donc ça
concrètement moi je passe plus mes
week-ends comme avant à trier ranger
astiquer laver non ça c'est fini vous
allez récupérer du temps et ça c'est un
autre avantage hyper important
aujourd'hui on court un petit peu après
notre vie et bien avoir moins chez soi
ça va permettre de récupérer du temps
pour soi plutôt que pour des choses qui
nous entourent
un autre aspect que j'avais pas du tout
anticipé et qui m'a vraiment surprise
c'est la créativité
ça développe la créativité à un point
inimaginable
comment venir si on a moins on fait
moins de choses et vous donner un
exemple
moi j'ai vécu à peu près 18 un temps
chez mes parents
les placards sont blindés il ya toutes
les sortes de pâtes que vous voulez il
ya du riz vous faites ce que vous voulez
il ya du basmati du taille du risotto ce
que vous voulez on peut tenir un siège
et pourtant pendant 18 ans j'ai entendu
ma mère chaque jour dire qu'est ce qu'on
mange ce soir et je comprenais pas parce
que parce qu'il y avait tout ce qu'on
voulait et en fait en faisant le tri
chez moi et en commençant à faire mes
courses différemment j'ai compris parce
qu'en fait si j'achète pour une semaine
j'achète que du riz et les pâtes et j'ai
pas à côté de la semoule et bly ou tout
ce qu'on veut d'accord je vais faire à
manger je vais partir d'une chose
et de là je vais pouvoir imaginer ce que
je veux comme repas c'est comme un
artiste un artiste qui a besoin de créer
une oeuvre
il choisit d'abord son support avant
d'exprimer sa créativité
en fait il faut pas voir le manque de
choix comme une contrainte mais comme
une direction pour exprimer sa
créativité et ça ça a été une très belle
surprise
après il ya les avantages chez soi mais
il n'ya pas que ça il ya les avantages à
l'extérieur aussi
si vous retournez
avantage chez les petits commerçants si
pour tous si vous allez voir un
retoucheur pour refaire un pantalon
plutôt acheter un neuf
vous allez voir ça va redonner un petit
peu vie à votre quartier vous allez
retrouver du lien avec des gens avec qui
vous pensiez pas avoir du lien en allant
toquer chez votre voisin ou en proposant
des choses à votre famille etc
ça va ça va recréer des liens qui
aujourd'hui sont un petit peu perdues à
cause de la ville et enfin si on s'y met
tous ce qui serait magnifique
ça serait qu'on pourrait réduire
considérablement le la quantité des
déchets qu'on envoie en incinérateur et
en décharge
aujourd'hui on a pour projet de
reconstruire l'incinérateur d'ivry celui
dans lequel vont tous les déchets de
l'île saint denis par exemple pour 2
milliards d'euros
on pourrait en faire des choses avec 2
des choses bien plus intéressantes que
simplement brûler des déchets donc ça
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire nous
c'est un monde qu'on peut construire
ensemble ce qu'il faut faire c'est faire
le premier pas parce que c'est celui ci
qui coûte choisissez celui qui vous
semble le plus facile mettez un stop pub
sur votre boîte aux lettres
aller chercher le pain en prenant un
petit torchon pour éviter l'emballage
choisissez celui que vous préférez
choisissant un fait le premier pas le
reste viendra tout seul